la grande soirée des sur France
2 dans une quinzaine de minutes le
concert au Zénit une cinquantaine
d'artistes avec en meneuse de revue
Muriel Robin qui est notre invité mais
d'abord place aux images quelques temps
fort de ce spectacle
exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
Val dans les bras de
Nicolas
mais
Nicolas ne le Savit
pas Isabel a
attendu
attendu mais Patrick n'est
jamais non jamais
reparu de
[Applaudissements]
pourit poser dans les
mag sort du bureau elle passe aussitôt
chez sa cousine verte ensemble elle cour
au club pour aller danser le pour aller
danser le de la
musique la
musique les
éclair dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
dans
il faut effectivement regarder
l'émission C'est une surprise mriel
voilà Muriel Robin bonsoir vous êtes la
marine des de cette soirée et vous êtes
meneuse de revue de cette cinquantaine
d'artistes soirée unique exceptionnelle
quelle est la marque de fabrique de ce
zenite 98 écoutez il y a une marque de
fabrique qui est là tous les ans mais
qui est là à chaque fois plus forte
c'est vraiment une soirée magique pour
nous et je suis sûr pour les gens qui
vont la regarder il y a effectivement
une cinquantaine d'artistes les mêmes
des nouveaux on a vu quand t Marie
Mathieu enfin je veux pas pour les
découvrir euh je crois vraiment moi
quand j'y vais en tout cas on attend
tous nous les artistes cette soirée avec
impatience je crois je le ressens en
tout cas quand on l'a fait les artistes
viennent avec le meilleur d'eux-même
laissent le le reste au vestiaire il y a
quelque chose qui se passe qui est
absolument unique il faut regarder cette
émission il faut la regarder parce que
vous ferez partie d'une chaîne de
solidarité qui commence par les gens
évidemment qui ont besoin des Restos du
cœur qui passe en tout cas pour ce soir
par nous il faut la regarder parce que
ça Dona envie d'acheter les vidéos et
que ça reviendra sur en repas l'année
dernière cette soirée en tout cas les
vidéos ont engrangé 18 millions de
francs c'est beaucoup de repas c'est 10
% du budget total de de l'association
Les Restos du cœur euh voilà et en quoi
l'esprit de Coluche est toujours présent
dans cette manifestation qui est ce soir
en tout cas un immense divertissement
écoutez je ne sais si on doit mettre un
nom sur l'esprit de Coluche j'ai pas
pensé mais il est question d'humanité de
solidarité de cœur sont les restau du
cœur et comme je vous le disais les gens
à ce moment-là laissent parler cette
chose-là mettre ça devant euh voilà donc
donc
euh il faut aller on va comment dire
c'est vraiment quelque chose de mais
vraiment c'est j'en ai encore l'émotion
parce que c'est vraiment quelque chose
de fort qui se passe et qui va aller
jusqu'aux gens j'en suis sûr c'est un
moment vraiment unique on vous sent très
militante pour ça je veux bien l'être ce
n'est pas ma nature mais pour ça oui
c'est alors sans dévoiler toute la
soirée quand même quelques moments forts
quelques surprises-delà des moments
forts je dirais que cette année on a on
s'améliore d'année en année on a
toujours peur moi je me dis toujours
comment la prochaine ne va pas être
aussi bon l'année dernière j'avais un
souvenir formidable c'est encore
audessus cette année parce qu'on a fait
une mise en scène on a des les artistes
sont en costume alors ça permet de voir
tout d'un coup ils s'oublient sont en
costume donc il joue un peu la comédie
Cabrel devient un gagman et un garçon
très drôle moi je l'avais jamais vu
comme ça et on a effectivement des gens
nouveaux d'un décor et les artistes
reviennent plus souvent tout au long de
l'émission c'est-à-dire qu'une fois
qu'on les a vu on les revoit au au cours
de l'émission il y a des moments de
comédie euh donc qui sont très drôles et
euh voilà ça fait une soirée encore une
fois unique forte qu'il faut regarder
pour pour un moment de solidarité bien
sûr et de bonheur j'en suis sûr aussi
vous allez nous surprendre vous-même je
l'espère en
quoi vous m'avez déjà vu en en marié
avec un truc à plume donc marié un peu
marié un peu bizarre mais la soirée va
surprendre parce qu'elle est vraiment
différente je remercie MRI Rob je crois
qu'on aura compris votre message merci